I think a healthy dose of skepticism is
one of the most important attributes one
can have but also saying most of us
could use a little more of you guys know
I'm big on definitions around here so
let's actually define the word
skepticism before we go any further an
attitude of doubt or disposition to
incredulity either in general or toward
a particular object the doctrine that
true knowledge or knowledge in a
particular area is uncertain the method
of suspended judgment systemic doubt or
criticism characteristic of skeptics
doubt concerning basic religious
principles as immortality Providence and
revelation so all skepticism really is
then is the desire for more information
before making a judgment this seems like
a really simple and pretty obvious
concept yet we're so lacking it in our
public discourse we're so quick to
dismiss people the second they say
something we don't like we ignore
evidence when it doesn't fit our
narrative and too often we pick sides
when we don't really know the facts this
is why pundits on cable networks radio
and online media or yelling all the time
instead of making a compelling argument
based on fact and reason they just yell
with righteous indignation so you think
that what they're saying must be true
after all they're really fired up so
they must have a true and decent cause
right well usually the opposite is true
of course it's not just these talking
heads who could use a healthy dose of
skepticism we're in the midst of an
election year so all of us should be
skeptical of everything each one of
these politicians running for office
says we shouldn't take their word for it
instead we should question whether what
they're saying is true and take the time
to learn the facts politicians prey on
an uninformed uninterested and non
skeptical electorate it's our job as
citizens to make them more honest and
more forthright pretty sure we all know
they're not going to do that on their
own going even deeper it's not just
pundits and politicians we should be
skeptical about but it's also our very
selves the word skeptic even has a
slight tinge of negativity to it right
like oh he's a skeptic you better watch
out for him all the skeptic actually
wants is more information to form an
opinion on the world in a rational way
using facts and proven methods sure
that's not as comforting as blind faith
and it certainly isn't as easy but
perhaps the satisfaction is in the
journey of questioning my guest this
week is Michael Shermer an author who
has written much on this subject and as
a thought leader in the skeptic movement
using science and provable methods he
talks about how we can have morality
that is based in fact not fiction it's a
harder Road but it is one that more and
more people seem to be taking it's also
an idea I try to use in all my
interviews I'm the first to admit that I
don't know everything and I'm genuinely
curious to learn from people of all
walks of life talking directly to them
is one of the few ways that we can
actually do that 140 characters is nice
but there's nothing like the true
personal connection at the end of the
day none of us truly know the meaning of
life and the answer to the big questions
we can think we can guess we can create
we can destroy but we simply cannot know
it's the age-old question that will
remain until the end of time in a way
not knowing is perhaps the most human
trait there is so when preachers
politicians or conspiracy theorists tell
you they know what's really going on
just know that they're full of something
but it ain't knowledge